Elizabeth diebold senior editor of
enlightening scene
this new study that's been done that
that has shown that women are less happy
than they have been since the 70s that
at the start of the women's movement
women were appear to be happier than
then they they're reporting now now
there are a lot of different ways to
think about what that means and what
that's about it could be that women were
to locked into being good women than to
say that they were unhappy I mean that
could be part of it could be just you
know greater honesty on women's part but
I think that if you look at what's
happened over the last almost 40 years
women's role which is the role that
women have been has given women dignity
that women have been known known for
have been identified with which is being
caretakers being the ones who kind of
hold the hearth together that hold the
heart of culture has become optional
it's not something that that you have to
do anymore it's not seen as you know we
hope that the women's roles will be
valued more but those traditional rules
still have not been are still not seen
as the most valuable part of culture and
so it's like the thing by which we've
we've known ourselves and that we have
you know by which we've understood how
to be in the world has been made not so
necessary and and yet the world of work
the workplace is still very much
structured as if it's for you know men
who have wives at home who are taking
care of the kids so we're in a very very
funny place we're kind of you know at a
point of a real transition in the
culture and I think that a large part of
women's unhappiness has to do with not
feeling where they're supposed to be and
and I think the thing is that there that
there isn't a supposed to be any more
you know that there isn't a you know a
place that that is going to be safe for
women you know that that we can fall
lined and you know that week where we
can be secure I think that if you think
about what makes a lot of women around
the world happy or would make them happy
would be safety security in many ways
that world is gone particularly for post
modern women in the West and so what
what new do we do we have that would be
as as fulfilling and and and you know be
able to tap something very deep in us
that allows us to make a contribution
that question really hasn't been
answered yet and I think because of that
that at a deep level women because what
this study pointed to is that it's
actually women all over the globe it's
not just post modern Western women but
women all over the globe or reporting
less happiness and I think that that's
because women around the world can can
look and see options when they don't
have any and that that is a source of
unhappiness and those of us who do have
options say say but I don't know what to
do I don't know really what it what it
what I can do that will really make my
life meaningful and give me a deeper
purpose for being here because all the
traditional ones don't really you know
don't really hold hold our hearts and
our passions and our our creativity any
longer
we'll women end up taking on sort of the
male role that work is is you know work
as our identity I mean a lot of women
have done done that and a lot of those
women are asking the same question
what's the purpose you know what's the
point of doing this you know is this
really creating the world that I want
and I think that the next then I think
the next step for women is is going to
be really interrogating and really in
inquiring into into the question of
purpose you know what what are we doing
here you know what what is it what can
we build together what can we create
together with how can we come together
to be a force in culture I was talking
to someone today who's who is a very
very well respected convener of large
large processes you know like like the
kinds of things that that that have been
done like at the UN or you know these
these sort of international convenings
and and I said something about about you
know women need needing to find a deeper
authority in themselves and finding a
deeper purpose from that authority and
he said yes because women give up and I
think that you know a lot of businesses
at this point see that investing in
women is difficult because women often
leave it's like why do i why would I
train someone for seven years and then
have her split and women are saying and
why do I want to be there when I don't
really feel that it's making a
difference so I think that there's going
to be a new and energized conversation
about what are we doing here what world
are we creating and I think that that's
something that women need to to begin to
do together but not in a way like it was
done in the 70s where it was we're doing
this together and we're because we're
victimized by men but we're doing this
together because
there are structures in ourselves that
our that keep us from being able to be
the kinds of agents of change that that
we need to be in order to create the
world that we want
no I think I think I think men have have
a need for purpose and I think if you
look at younger men and you know you
look at men in their their 20s 30s sort
of the gen Gen X and Gen Y generations I
think part of what what is going on
there is they're saying what's the point
you know what are you kidding me do you
want you know I'm going to work for 20
years in this in this business and get
what for it you know it's like and they
do things in around the world that I
don't I don't feel that I can be behind
you don't forget about it now we're
talking about young people at the
leading edge of culture we're not
talking about the kind of the vast swath
of folks who are you know who are living
more in a more traditional context we're
talking about people who have whose
lives have been kind of blown open by
the last 40 years and who came of you
know who have grown in come of age in a
world where hey you pick your life you
know you choose what you want to do and
in that context it's like there's
there's a real I think a lot of young
men feel very confronted by well what
can I do it would make a difference if
it would matter anyway I think this is
true for many you know young men and
young women and I think men of the older
generation you know boomer men I think
are more part of the system and and have
been part of the system and and find
find more you know more of a sense of
congruence with you know I'm making this
happen it's my the world you know my
business it's my project it's I'm making
this happen and I find meaning in that
and you know i mean i'm a master of my
own universe and i'm creating something
in the world and I'm proud of that and I
think that that that world is a world
that is that that I think younger people
have feel less able to kind of enter and
engage with and don't want to come in at
the bottom and which may be a misguided
notion but they you know the the sense
of I think a sense of purpose for all of
us is becoming only more and more urgent
I think recreational sex has been
something that's been around for quite
some time and certainly has been has
exploded into popular culture in the you
know with the 60s generation sex has
become you know more and more and more
commoditized you know I read a article
recently about prostitution being a new
a new like lucrative life choice for
four young women I think it was the new
freakonomics book was mentioning that
but it it's you know where sex in the
marketplace have have created quite an
alliance and you know commoditizing you
know women's sexuality i mean this is
this is like everybody knows that all
you have to do is look around you you
know and and you can you can see that
but what whether or not there what's
fascinating is in this context where
women are very much sexualized and
commoditized in in the marketplace that
that young women are remarkably
percentage-wise non orgasmic and I find
that absolutely fascinating that you
that the same young women who are
strutting their stuff and acting super
confident in relationship to their
sexuality are often not having or
experiencing pleasure in you know in
insects at least not not at the orgasm
level and I think that that that shows
that there's a real disjunct between
what it is that that young women want
and and need in order to really be stay
really connected with themselves and and
sort of where the culture has been going
so will will there be some kind of push
back in relation to that I don't know
but I think that that I think that women
need need to start having a conversation
about this
the way to women want you know I think
if you you have to ask the question what
which women you know who are we talking
about and because I think that for most
women on this planet what they want is
security a safe place to be able to
raise their children you know a way to
have ensure that their children's lives
are in some way better than their own
these are classic things that women have
wanted for probably four millennia but
if you're asking it of you know of
someone who watches big think who are
typically more progressive you know
educated postmodern women what do we
want it I think that what we want is the
capacity to really make a difference and
to to have a deeper connection with with
an authentic source of power with a
deeper deeper deeper way of being that
allows us to have a kind of confidence
that that is very rare and women I think
we want dignity respect and those things
are hard come by for us women if you
look at when you look at the the
landscape of billboards and
advertisements and television shows you
don't see a lot of women with with with
dignity you know that's that's not
that's not a characteristic of you know
of a woman and in popular culture at
this point and so I think that they're
there are the very deep things that
women are looking for a new role in
culture a new a new way to be able to to
be active and engaged co-creators of
culture with you know with men and
that's not been our role ever and I
think that women are hungry to to be
able to do that and the thing is we
often give up before long before we ever
even really
start to make make any headway or we
give up very too easily on on that dream
of making a difference and having a
deeper purpose and authenticity and
authority
I think that because our when the going
we're very conflict avoidant I think
that when when the going gets tough and
things get you know the creative
friction starts and you're not sure
where things are going to go I think
that we we women often want to control
things and that's not the way to get to
you know to create something new or we
withdraw you know and and in in many
ways that's that's the how we withdraw
from the edge of a creative process with
other people you know we're afraid of
the conflict so it's like okay so
everyone be quiet now or no we're going
to do it some other way or or I'm out of
here and I think that because sort of
having a role as as kind of an equal
partner and and real co-creator in in
culture is is still to a great extent
optional that too is optional you know
the being being a you know a wife and
mother is now optional and also but also
having you know work in the world and
engaging as a as a creator in culture is
also optional so whenever things get
tough you can back out and I think that
there's I think there are very very deep
reasons why kind of a kind of backing
away and and self-protection is is kind
of a almost an instinctive reaction in
women to things when they when they get
charged and when they get tough and and
to be able to sort of be in touch with a
deeper creative impulse that allows you
to really engage and allows you to
engage creativity creatively and with
that kind of creativity that you don't
know where it's going to go you don't
know what's going to happen next you're
not sure you know whether or not the
room is going to explode someone's going
to get upset you don't know what's going
to happen you know to be able to really
drive from from that place in yourself
that's not a place that women are are
accustomed to to being you know to
coming from and as a result we we often
opt out give up and
uptown